feeling very good about that the
basketball i.q and as a head coach EJ
it's got to be terrific feeling knowing
you've got multiple coaches over there
on the bench and we haven't talked about
that Jimmy but those going in there and
extending this foot part of the deal
that brought Meyers Leonard here and put
him in a sheath uniform as well three on
the shot clock
Butler recognizing rising up and knocks
it down from deep Miami Heat getting
everything early and Jimmy Butler shot
clock running down
not the hero the navigate past look for
a new Dre takes his right to the rim
watch Kelly who brie on this though is
he he's on the pass and he stuff that
left arm out to turn the flat out shoot
it talked openly about the player that
he loves to emulate is Jimmy Butler
carrying the heat early he's got 14 they
know if they do miss a couple of shots
and going to court they'll get another
chance but there's the Jimmy Butler
Butler kicks it out to Jones for the
call move it here nice Rockets coming
off the bench now for the heat inside
and Jimmy Butler with 18 on six of seven
shooting from the fees aisle outside
Rubio
stepping out extend the defense on a big
man through all the deck Butler with a
step-back three Jimmy is officially
dialed and
he's really not that aggressive
offensive player where he's gonna take a
ton of shots right back to the finger
roll short the butler some house living
between the two sub players
Butler will get an A in law
scoring comparison amongst the key
players Jimmy Butler's show it continues